so that myers-briggs thing was super
interesting to me yeah
and it's crazy so so that
formula for breaking down someone's
personality was
was a very it was a thing that you
carried with you everywhere ever you use
that as a tool for
still right now like what i did to you
that day
which i hope you didn't feel offended or
anything but but that's a tool i use
with
everything with me with every business
uh
partner with every possible like every
new collaborator
when i'm getting coffee from a barista
right like i am constantly assessing
personality according to those
myers-briggs 16 personality
uh type indicator options yeah it's an
awesome tool
and everybody gets it wrong because you
read cosmo magazine and you read men's
health you read all this
this garbage mainstream media that tells
you you're supposed to know your own
personality what what the hell is the
purpose of knowing your own personality
just because you know what you are isn't
doesn't make it
a powerful tool for you to use it's like
like looking at yourself in the mirror
and you're like oh i've got black hair
and a beard
well huzzah that's that's you knew that
already right
you found out that you fall you fell
into four
type indicator labels that didn't teach
you anything new about you
you were like oh that's why i like to
sit and read
and that's why it gives me energy when i
do that and this is why you know i make
a decision and i go with my decision
it didn't tell you anything new that you
didn't already know what's powerful is
when you use personality type profiling
as a tool against other people because
if you can identify their personality
type
through a conversation now all of a
sudden you know way more about them
than they know about you does that make
sense yeah absolutely i know it's
twisted i know
it's not often a popular concept for
people but that's how i use personality
yeah it's just it's just hard to
remember a lot of it you know what i
mean like it's
it's very nuanced with the different
types of uh
like like under each category whether
it's introvert extrovert
feeling thinking i mean there's so many
different
uh you know variables to each one of
those so
i'm let me and if you if you're down for
it i'll give you my quick rule of thumb
that i always use to remember it yeah
right
so the you got 16 letters well
you've got eight letters essentially and
16 combinations of those letters the
combinations all the big numbers don't
matter all you've got to think about to
understand a human being's personality
any culture
any age any gender any level of
education right backed by science
all you have to do is remember four
questions one the first question is
where does a person get their energy
is it do they get their energy being
alone do they get their energy being
around other people
that's your that's your extrovert versus
your introvert
if that person spends time alone
and that and being alone makes them feel
more energetic
like you when you read a book by
yourself you come out of it feeling more
energetic
when i read a book by myself dude i
don't read a book by myself i fall
asleep
it's it's it's a huge drain on me to be
alone in a quiet place
doing something oh it's miserable i am
an extrovert
so right there's the first question
where does a person get their energy
alone
or in a group knowing that about
somebody else
right away you know if you want that
person's attention
if you want that person's trust if you
want that person's best
ideas you have to put them in the
environment that suits them
take them away from people if i want to
have a meaningful conversation with you
i would not take you to a bar
that's just going to drain your energy
it's going to suck up your time and your
effort right
if i take you to like a coffee shop a
nice quiet coffee shop or if we go have
a private dinner in a private room at a
nice restaurant
just you and me and and like good food
good drinks
that's that's just setting you up for
success which setting you up for success
is setting me up for success
in the spy world right exactly so that's
introvert extrovert
make sense yeah before you move on to
the next one how do you tell if somebody
how do you tell
after just meeting somebody whether
they're an introvert or an extrovert so
you can watch their cues as they spend
time with you
but the real benefit the real advantage
is asking them
questions about what you know is
extrovert and introvert behavior like i
asked you questions that day i was like
oh what do you do
when you're when you have free time
you're like oh i just love to sit on the
sofa and just
hang out i like to read i'll watch a
movie like i like my
i like my me time my wife likes her me
time too right
everybody who is an introvert will have
a concept and some definition of their
me time
right my escape room my she shed my
my me time people who are extroverts you
will never hear me talk about me time
you'd be like what do you like to do and
it's fun i was like oh i like to go out
to the beach with some friends i like to
go on a boat i like to go have some
adventure like we always talk about
adventure have a good buddy of mine
who's still at the agency and we used to
just
text each other on the weekends when we
were single be like we need we need to
go on an adventure i'm
i'm bored like we need to go do
something and it was sometimes it was
stupid stuff like mountain biking
through gettysburg
in the snow but it was something that we
would do
together because we could and we didn't
want to be alone because that just
drains us of energy how do you do on
long road trips by yourself
i don't it's miserable i love them i i
have a
i have a good buddy of mine who's a
sales coach in the area
and he runs his primary like
business is running atm machines and all
he does is drive around florida
restocking atm machines
right and then he coaches people on how
to run their own business and how to
sell the same way he basically sells his
atm machines
he spends like six hours a day in the
car six days a week
and loves it every time i talk to him
i'm like that sounds like torture
i have to go to miami in like three
weeks i am seriously considering
flying to miami just because i don't
want to sit in the car
for three and a half hours by myself
listening to an audiobook
[Laughter]
dude i absolutely love road trips alone
if i didn't do
like if i could choose any other
profession i think i would choose being
a truck driver
wow one of those big sleepers in the
back going across the country
it's a big part of why i left the air
force too when i started flying and i
realized how similar flying was to
driving
because it's you're just burning holes
in the sky all those pilots out there
those air force pilots even if they're
in like an f-16
they go on like a seven hour sortie
alone
in a cockpit just like you're alone
behind a wheel just driving
just flying right and that just sounded
miserable to me that's so wild
[Laughter]
so well people can feel so different
about those things and
that's what's so powerful about it man
nobody's very few people stop to reflect
on what
brings me energy we're all too tied up
in what does society expect
so there's specific questions you can
ask to figure out definitively
what type of person that is yeah it's
not necessarily specific questions as
much as it's you know you're targeting
specific areas with the questions you're
asking
right what do you like to do in your
free time is one of those questions
um you know what what's what do you
remember
as a kid really liking like if you talk
to somebody like i used to love drawing
as a kid
boom there's somebody who is probably an
introvert i used to love reading
i used to love watching movies i used to
love playing by myself and then you're
going to have those kids who are like oh
i love playing soccer
oh i love going to the playground you
know i love school most of the people
who say they love school
love school because of the social aspect
of school okay right that's not they
don't say they love school because they
love their
geometry teacher they love hanging out
with their friends and basically a bus
delivers them to a social outlet
and then a bus delivers them home at the
end of the day it's a good deal for an
extrovert right okay what's the next the
next part of it all right so then you go
from
your e your extrovert your introvert
your e your i you go into your intuitor
or your sensor your n and your s all
that means is does
do you do you take data
that has math behind it like do you use
your sensory organs your your five
senses
to collect data or do you
just use your intuition to collect data
so sensor s uses the five senses to
collect data
intuitor uses intuition to collect data
so if i if i believe something i believe
it when i see it
i believe it when i taste it i believe
it when i smell it right that's a sensor
i believe it because i believe it that's
an intuitor
so if somebody who's an s you're gonna
have to prove it to them by showing them
letting them touch it whatever right
if it's an intuitor all it has to do is
make sense to them logically
in their own mind and their own belief
set and they're going to believe it
right intuitors are the reason that
religions exist
right because what is what is faith what
is islam what is christianity what is
buddhism
right i believe it is true that's just
intuition that's just you believing
something
nobody can prove it you can't touch it
taste it feel it whatever right
even when you feel like you're being
moved by the holy spirit or when you
feel like
you know you have been touched by
enlightenment it's just a
it's just intuition it's something that
you can't describe
so when you talk to somebody and you
hear them like
referenced data through their senses
i went to this place the lights were low
the walls had this cool yellow glow
right the music was the perfect level
it was great sounding those are they're
describing their environment they're
describing data
through their five senses but when you
go somewhere and they're like oh i felt
like
a million bucks they treated me so good
i i can't wait to go back there again
right
now that's somebody who's just talking
through their own interpretation their
own intuit
in their own intuition about what they
experienced there okay
so that's the same thing when you and i
were talking i don't
hear you say anything about like i'm i
complimented your audio i complimented
your video setup and all this stuff that
had to do with five senses
and you were unenthused to talk about
any of those things right but when we
started talking about personality
you just lit right up and you're like oh
that's so interesting just because i
could
like you had intuitive cogs in your head
just spinning
and that's what a lot of folks are a lot
of folks are intuitors it's hard
sometimes to find sensors
interesting yeah my wife who is my total
opposite
is a sensor i get excited about stuff
just because it's exciting to me
right and then trying to convince her to
get excited it's like pulling teeth
it's insane dude it's like oh i got this
great idea babe
we're gonna go do this with the kids on
the weekend it's gonna be sweet
and she's like whoa what are we gonna do
when we get there how are we gonna get
there
what are the kids gonna wear what's the
weather supposed to look like what are
we gonna eat on the way there
like what's the plan for lunch when we
get there and i'm like i don't have any
of that
we're just we're going to the beach
let's just go it's going to be sweet
how could it not be sweet yeah so that's
the difference between an
intuiter and a sensor okay so how do
they interpret data your second question
right
first one where do they get their energy
second one how do they interpret data
got it okay
your third one if you want to move on to
the third yep your feeler
right versus your perceiver your f
versus your p
feelers make this is the question here
is how do they make their decisions
feelers make their decision based on
their gut my gut tells me to do this
my gut tells me to do that that's that
is my feeling
this is right this is wrong it's how it
feels to me
right perceivers are perceiving
the best decision based on what's
available to them
based on either intuition or sensit or
sensory data
right so both are looking back at their
previous you know the data piece
and then they're using that data to make
a decision but what decision are they
making
right gut feelers make their gut
decisions perceivers make a decision
based off of what they think
is their processing their analytical
reasoning
okay right like that beach example for
me i wanted to go to the beach with my
kids because it's going to be freaking
sick
that's just me being a perceiver based
on my intuition
every other time i've gone to the beach
it's been a lot of fun i think it's
going to be fun this time i'm a p
let's go my wife who's a feeler her gut
instinct is like
i don't think this feels right and then
she leans back on her
being an s and she's like how's it going
to look how's it going to feel how's it
going to touch
like where are we going to eat and then
all of a sudden it all falls apart
so wow and maybe it's not as simple as i
promised you it would be
after no it makes perfect sense no i get
it i get it especially
the test took me like two hours today
yeah it sucks to go through it sometimes
and that's a big part of the reason why
people don't get a really accurate
representation because you take these
tests online or you take a test in a
magazine it's got like 11 questions
that doesn't tell you anything like to
really take a proper
myers-briggs exam an actual eval
psychoeval it takes hundreds of
questions
and the questions have to be like
cross-referenced whether
whether automatically or by a
professional but the thing is i feel
like i can be both
on both sides of those things like
sometimes i'm a feeler and sometimes i'm
more analytical and sometimes i combine
the two like if i'm really thinking
about a critical
thing i need answered or i'm trying to
make a critical decision on something
i i use my gut and i use
my analytical evaluating tools yeah
absolutely you can
right because this is what's powerful
about personality personality does not
tell you what you're limited to
personality tells you what you default
to
right so it's like when you are having a
good day when you're in your zone
and you have all the resources you can
imagine you had a good night's rest you
had a good
meal you feel good you've got like all
the computers
are running and they're all running at
top speed right you can use
everything you can use your analytical
side your feeling side you can use your
sensory side you can use your perception
side you can use
historical evidence you can fight off
the urge to take a nap
if you're by my if you're by yourself i
mean i can go for a long drive i can
fight off the urge to sleep
but that's not what personality is
personality is what is your default
when all the resources are taken away
and thrown out the window when you're
under pressure when you're under stress
when you are under arrested
what's left what are you gonna do
by default that is your myers-briggs
personality
okay that's why it's so powerful for
spies that's why it's so powerful in
espionage
foreign